gee I am challenging myself to learn as
much Farsi as I can for a month yeah
we're talking what and then I want to
try and have a conversation with my Baba
with my dad
100 percent spoken in Farsi I am happy
Rania
my dad was born in Mashhad Iran and my
mom was born in Des Moines Iowa my
family grew up in Iowa so growing up my
family my parents were both very good
about introducing the Iranian culture in
our lives and just making it part of who
we were we were very familiar with the
food in the art and the music a big part
of what was missing from my childhood
from growing up was actually being able
to speak the language and knowing the
language I still do regret growing up
not really trying harder to learn the
language
and I do wish I understood it more
because there's this lack of
understanding and connection something I
hope fiercely wanted ever since I can
remember
and I'm actually hoping that this is
just the beginning of my frankly
lifelong journey of really truly
learning the language I'm really excited
to finally finally just push myself and
get started I'm gonna go ahead and start
simple
yeah Buddha's a fine coach honest
people need to need to have visit today
is already the fourth and first five
lessons I have attempted to learn Farsi
several times since I was young now I am
on lesson eight it's a definite
challenge this time the word
just haven't really stuck yet I still
can't forget shopping
[Music]
I'm realizing that a lot of the lessons
between about 12 to 15 are still a
little bit difficult for me to do so I
guess I'm just going to review them the
lessons and then see what kind of
conversation I can attempt to have with
my Baba I'm not even sure what I can
talk to him about based on the lessons
I've been learning because a lot of it
has to do with buying stuff at a store
and bargaining I'm learning how to
bargain in lessons I'm very much
unprompted now told him asked again in
dollars how much would it be they do not
turn to me [ __ ] later we're going to go
Nick turn lead the attack but then if
I'm actually in the conversation sending
where the person is talking I'm not sure
if I'll be able to just like think of it
I definitely want to just try to keep
going with it though
[Music]
me shea-porter him the d-pad it's a
surprise I don't think he knows yet I've
told my mom what I'm doing but I haven't
told him so we'll see how it goes
do you need an okay ma che ba check on
Nimmi from car Kona na na car all
weekend I just got off the phone with my
dad and I would say it was about 40% in
Farsi so it wasn't a hundred percent of
Farsi I mean all things considered it
went pretty well I realized that I don't
know anything about speaking in the past
tense so I wasn't sure how to say what
did you eat her dinner but we figured it
up like after seeing his face when we
first started talking we'll just light
up that's encouraging enough to me to
want to keep going and keep learning
this language and keep building on what
I've already learned my dad had
mentioned something about wishing that
we my siblings and I had learned the
language growing up as kids but at the
same time you're never too old and it's
never too late to pick it up and to
learn a new skill or any
language and hey it's okay and I'm
learning it now and yeah I'm just really
excited for this journey to continue
[Music]